unser korrespondent für die region ist
ulf röller schönen guten tag wie heike
wäre denn ein besuch bloß es jetzt in
time
ich glaube das wäre schon sehr heikel
für die region der präsident china
shipping hat ja noch mal sehr deutlichen
telefonat mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten beiden gesagt wenn per los
sie kommt ist dass das spiel mit dem
feuer und es gibt viele hinweise in der
amerikanischen medien das eigentlich man
davon ausgeht dass pelosi nach taiwan
kommt das würde zu einer eskalation
führen das wäre ein wirkliches problem
man hat sich ja hier in eine krise quasi
reingeredet beide weltmächte wenn große
jetzt nicht nach taiwan fahren würde
dann sähe es so aus als könnte china
quasi amerika diktieren wer taiwan
besucht und dann sähe amerika schwach
aus und umgekehrt wenn sie nach taiwan
reißt und die chinesen nicht massiv
reagieren dann sehe china und der
präsident shipping schwach aus und das
will der nicht was kann passieren ich
glaube nicht dass wir irgendwie in der
richtung denken müssen von einem
militärischen konflikt aber es kann
durchaus passieren dass was die chinesen
angedroht haben wenn klose im flugzeug
sitzt das sie dann begleitet wird vom
chinesischen kampfjets und diese dann
auch den taiwanesischen luftraum quasi
ein drängen das wäre ein hohes
symboldbild bild quasi die amerikanische
parlamentspräsidentin begleitet von
chinesen kampfjets also etwas was man
nicht unbedingt will andere symbolbilder
gab es auch am wochenende da gab es ein
seemanöver chinas in der nähe von taiwan
mit scharfer munition
wie ist das zu beurteilen
ja es gibt immer wieder manöver in
dieser region und dieser region wird
auch massiv aufgerüstet weil eben nicht
nur die amerikaner sagen diese region da
haben wir große interessen sondern auch
japan und südkorea rüsten massiv auf und
eben china rüstet massiv auf das ist
quasi dort die entscheidende region für
die neue weltordnung was das problem
eigentlich war dass diese manöver
normalerweise langfristige angekündigt
werden bei der gegenseite als in diesem
fall bei den amerikanern dass man nicht
ist das mazal ob aus zufall in
irgendeinen konflikt heinrich rein rennt
diesmal war das sehr kurzfristig
angekündigt daran sieht man wie schwer
das vertrauen eben zerstört es insgesamt
gilt diese region wird macht neu
verteilt die chinesen sehen das als
ihren politischen hinterhof an sowie das
amerika lange in lateinamerika gesehen
hat und sie wollen dort das sagen haben
und sie glauben auch dass sie diese
aufstrebende weltmacht ist dass
irgendwann durchsetzen ob es wirklich
dann irgendwann mal zur militärischen
konflikt kommt wie gesagt da wäre ich
sehr vorsichtig weil das würde auch die
ökonomische sicherheit der region zu
schaden und damit auch die chinesische
wirtschaft treffen aber es wird immer
wieder an den nächsten jahren dort ein
brennpunkt bleiben einschätzungen von
unserem china korrespondenten ulf röller
vielen dank